I
good morning everyone welcome back so
now we have an eagle Schmidt who came in
from Hamburg where he's currently faced
with Jimdo and he joined Jimdo after
studying physics at tu dresden so honey
wanna take away yeah thank you yeah I'm
going to talk about um Abby Abby is a
django app that's intended to document
all your a bee tests and before we start
I want to say some words about myself so
I'm working as a as a data scientist for
Jim do Jim do is a do-it-yourself
website builder which was founded in
2007 in Hamburg Germany and currently we
have more than 180 employees in three
different offices in Germany in the
United States and in Japan and already
more than 10 million web sites were
built using our service if you're
interested in following me on Twitter
then you can see my handle down there
it's at dot money and okay so now let's
dive right in who of you knows what a be
testing means okay so basically all of
you and who has already done in a be
test okay half of you okay so i will
have some words about what a/b testing
is but i will go over it quite quickly
so basically it's what you know from
from the medicine that you have a
control group which gets a placebo which
basically has no effect and then you
have one or more test groups that gets
you actually a truck and you seeing if
this test group is performing better
than a control group and if you have
internet companies and your control V
basically it's your old version of your
website or even something you don't have
yet in terms of features and your test
group is one on one new words that you
want to test and we did quite a lot of a
be testing a gym 'do and
like everybody you're doing that we
encountered some problems and out of
these problems we had derived some rules
and best practices we want to keep the
first one is or the first rule that we
put up as always frame your hypothesis
before really thinking about the test so
we don't just say okay I want to raise
my conversion rate but say okay I want
to improve the design of my landing page
to improve the conversion rate for a
particular group the next one is keep it
simple so there are many fancy setups
where you can have four or five six or
even more tests boobs but there will be
some challenges in the test setup and
also in the test evaluation so we always
try to keep it as simple as possible let
me try to have only one test group and
both of these groups are in best case
equally sized and also users aren't in
more than one test at one time and the
third rule is always set a time frame
before your test actually starts so that
is pretty important like if you're using
tools like Google Analytics for a be
testing and you always can see how your
test is performing and if you're looking
at a test is just running for two days
new CEO really great there is a
significant result I just stopped the
test then yeah you probably it's
possible that this significant results
after two days would have vanished with
more users so it's not really a hard
foundation that you're about you build
upon with a smaller sample size so
always say okay I'm running this test
for two weeks or until exhales and users
are in the test and yes there's also
three best practices that we have the
first one is always be realistic about
what you can achieve with a be
so if you're quite successful internet
company then probably nothing is so
wrong that you can improve something by
600 or 700 consent like you see in some
online blogs where by changing the color
of a culture action button you raised
your conversion rate six hundred percent
or so that's really not realistic and
another one is always grab the
low-hanging fruits first so you can /
optimize every part of your website but
if you have a block on one very basic
step for you user acquisition for
example then all this over optimization
in a special place won't benefit you at
all and the last one is don't get
frustrated because most of the tests
will fail you're doing a be testing
because your intuition isn't that good
but it's also not that bad that your
first version didn't work at all okay
now I'm going to have two minutes of
science I don't know who of you probably
all of you most of you will know what
significance in statistical power is
right or who knows what significance in
statistical power is okay quite a lot
okay so I just can skip over its or
significance is how often will have
failed test lead to a positive result of
course it should be C represent but at
most five percent it's this famous p
value and statistical power is how often
will you recognize a successful test in
the first place and of course you want
to recognize every successful test
button realistic set ups you say okay
it's better than eighty percent so it is
a good statistical power and these are
the evaluation metrics that we are
always trying to report when doing a be
tested in New so the first one I'll set
the p value and is it statistical power
that I mentioned
earlier the next one's the effect size
so basically a normalized difference of
the means between control and testable
and the last one is the confidence
interval okay so then let's do a little
AP test and see why better documentation
will benefit and where it can help us so
imagine you have this landing page we
have some men looking at the side of
your website not looking directly at you
and then you have some login box and
your hypothesis is that by changing to a
more direct look or by a guy you will
raise the activity of your users and
also the sales so I said citizen this
odd control group and this one is our
test me I really think it will perform
better and yes so you let it run for
several weeks or until you have some
sales and users in it you're going to
evaluate it and what's next so obviously
the first step is you have to
communicate the results in some way so
you have to go to your colleagues or to
your supervisors and say okay we did
this test we have some significant
results and we want to do that as this
and that so it is important that you're
absolutely clear about what you have
done and what implications about your
the implications of your tests are so
communicating is maybe the most
important thing that you have to do
after an a/b test so next one is of
course you want to persist the results
you want to always be able to go back
and
the discussion comes up and say okay we
did this test some months to go here it
is have a look at it we already know it
but it's also every a BTS that you're
doing is scientifically generated
knowledge that you have and it's really
am yeah really valuable because maybe
this is the only place where you can
really have a scientifically profound
data so an a/b test documentation also
serves as a knowledge base for your
company and another point is with a good
documentation you're going to avoid
duplicated tests or test suenos they
won't work for your customers because
you have done tests and you know if I
tried it with a more direct version
Lexus second landing as I showed you and
you know okay let just won't work then I
don't have to test it again so probably
you ask know if everybody has this
problem then there needs to be a
solution for it right but we didn't
quite a lot of research on google and so
we really didn't come up with a proper
solution so there are some specific
solution for example MailChimp offers a
be testing for the email campaigns but
it's not a general solution not for
every a/b test that you're doing and
another great advises you just used an
excel sheet or something but our opinion
we went to that path and was really
painful and it really didn't work out
quite well because it's a pain to
maintain it with different teams and
it's difficult to maintain of the
evaluation metrics that you want to have
and you can't filter properly and so
it's really not them as if the best
method for this kind of problem so what
did we come up with a gym new
Oh what basically what is Abby I me the
first most important thing is it's a
central place for our a be test
documentation so if we in the data team
do an a/b test or a developer or a
designer than everybody will I create a
test in a B and he will know what others
have done and he knows we had to look it
up and we also tried to design it in a
very simple and easy-to-use way so every
designer who hasn't done who hasn't a
lot of experience doing a/b test can
easily look at it and see this one
central place okay this was done on this
kind of users what was tested as easily
visible so you don't have to go to a
data scientist or so to consult about an
a/b test and it also helpful to keep
track of our evaluation metrics so there
was a problem before and we had a B then
I came up with a test and i wanted to
know what's the effect size of a test
and i was unable to find the numbers and
said I only found some our evaluation
scripts and was like oh there has to be
a better solution and that was really
the kick off point for starting
developing it and of course we also try
to encourage the best practices that you
saw earlier so if you're doing a test
and test on the same users is already
running then you will get a warning
saying hey here you haven't tested in
parallel on the same users I really sure
that you want to do this test again in
this time frame and that's what at least
it's also a Productivity game and that's
maybe the most important part for a
business so it's important enough that I
want to go into a little bit further
detail what I mean with it so at first
it's a reference for your daily work so
if you
pretty good documentation and you always
can come back in discussions and
reference it and say to your colleagues
okay we have done it these other results
and it's also starting point for
designing new maybe tests and of course
it also leads to cross functional
effects which is pretty important in our
opinion because we are very diverse
teams and a lot of different people
trying to do a pap test and if there's
this scenario energetic effects then a
designer can see email campaign for one
of our marketing guys and say hey we can
do it a lot better in a different place
maybe on the landing page directly and
maybe the most important part is with
each abts that you're doing you really
get a better understanding of your
customers you know what will work for
them and you even will get to know what
doesn't work for them so okay but now
enough for the theory how have you done
it obviously we're using pizen for it
and since it's a web app that we are
using django in the core or in the back
end we're using twitter bootstrap for
the front end because we have not
designers but we're going to have a
nice-looking app and we're also using
elastic search for full text search
capabilities so basically a B is a crap
so crowd as web developer speak for
create read update and delete so you can
create a test you can view it you can
update it and you can also delete it if
something went wrong then on top of that
we will the test evaluation logic for
automatic automatic test evaluation
using panels and stats models and as a
working progress we also have a restful
api where you have a nice interface for
the platform tools that you can directly
communicate okay but long story short
let's just
have a little demo about it and see what
I'm talking about you for all the time
so okay that's the start page for Evie
and what you're seeing here is basically
everything that I had in the first
slides was ruled for a be test the best
practices and the roots was a test
evaluations that we came up with and in
the navigation bar you have also a
button on an item for overview of all
the tests that are in a bee he has a
possibility to create a new test you
have a login button where we come back
to in a minute and you have a search
field which triggers is elastic search
that I mentioned earlier so okay now
let's have a look what ABT tests exists
already in a B and then you will see all
there isn't anything so but it just
tells you okay let's just create new
test which basically links with this
item and then you have a nice forum
where you can put up all the kind of
things you have a title for your AP test
you have an owner you have some
description you have a URL if you are
wanted to link to a ticket in your
ticket system or to some code snippet on
github you have a required start day to
have a optional enter date and then to
wear it quite gender specific fields for
languages and countries because most of
the times we're testing it either for a
specific language or in all adjusted in
Spain for example and not in Mexico and
of course you can also create tests that
are that were also already evaluated in
the past and so you have a text field a
markdown format the text field a way you
can just insert results for yourself and
you have a checkbox if this test
test has had significant results so okay
then let's walk through for example the
test that i came up with earlier so
we're saying okay this is a Jamie
resists Tyrion ending page test the
owner and myself we have a nut soul
great description of threat Game of
Thrones rugs obviously in a real test
you would have something way more
complex describing your test setup and
so on then you are aware to skipping
start abusing okay it's a first of July
and the end date is so the first of July
and we don't have any restrictions on
languages of countries and now we're
just saving it and then you seen oh ok I
messed up the description but everything
else is right here you have to die first
230 first of two lines so it's running
for 30 days you have this little
description in the bottom and you also
see that I have the possibility to
upload additional images to it so let's
just do that and just use who's Jamie
version one first and then you see okay
I have a the first son nail then also
uploading the second one okay and then
you see I have both my control and my
test group the images for my controlling
test group right in the test so if I'm
coming up with it later on then I'll
have a quick reference which exactly was
tested and if I just click on it and see
full screen image so if you look in the
overview then not very surprising that
there's one test and the status of the
test is running so okay so if you just
upload data test and you can have
finally the right description for it and
let's just say okay it didn't run to the
31st but all
tis the 15th of July you can update it
may have the right description you has
have a little text calling you that's a
sucker's it was updated successfully and
in the overview it's now saying oh it's
not significant because the test isn't
running anymore you haven't inserted any
or upload any results and haven't
clicked this little checkbox so IV is ok
that's not significant but now we're
coming back to this a little login
button that you saw earlier and if
you're just clicking on it and I have my
dummy credentials no I don't want to
save that one ok it looks better so
you're jumping back to the homepage
which maybe is not the yes yeah so
normally it wouldn't have this break in
it but it's kind of for the resolution
so I'm if you know just click on this
test and like before you have this
update to test possibility the debt
delete test possibility but you're also
seeing in evaluate test button and the
reason it's only visible if you're
logging in is if some marketing guys are
looking at then we really want to hide
it from them and only members of the
data team should evaluate tests
automatically because it's kind of
experimental still and what you're
seeing is you're prompted to upload a
file you have some things to put up and
now just have a look how this csv file
has to look so can you read in the end
okay okay so basically what you have you
have some kind of header and for each
participant in the test you have a
single row so the metrics that you have
are the active user the sales and some
flag telling you if this user was in the
test bubon to control
so for example my first user up here
which would have been active in some
kind of definition but he didn't buy
your product and he wasn't in the test
room and it was crawling down these are
randomly generated data so it's
basically just to abandon data frames
and here you can see this guy here he
wasn't active but he bought your product
and he was in the control so okay so I
would just select this test CSV file and
the split column basically is the column
and the head are telling you in this
column are the different tests and
control groups and like you can see up
here it was called test flag well that's
what we call it here and then your
observations are basically your KPIs
that you wanted to influence in this
case it was active user and sales and
where Ryan's is acquired technical term
but it's basically saying okay what r is
the different groups in this column test
flag and in this case it was just called
test and control but it could also be 0
or 1 test 1 and control one of something
else and the control label of course is
necessary if you wanted to know did the
test group perform better than the
control group that the evaluation
program knows what as a control group is
and in this case it's just control so
okay if you know click your way right
then you're taken back to the detail
view of the of the a/b test and nothing
has changed on the top but if you're
looking at the bottom and you can see
that the colorful table was added to it
and you can see the names p value the
uplift the confidence interval the power
for each for each metrics that you had
in this kind of in this case it was
active use on sales like you saw on the
csv file and you see that the active
users i had a p-well
of smaller than 0.05 and so this column
of this row is highlighted in green
indicating it's a significant test for
this metric and we had an uplift of six
percent basically I generated data in a
way that a control group had ten percent
conversion rate or activity rate and the
test group had sixteen percent and
you're seeing the confidence interval
telling you that the uplift is somewhere
between one point eight percent and 10.2
percent and you're also seeing the
statistical power it's 0.99 for so in 99
and four percent of the cases he would
detect in successful test and also
seeing that this sales wasn't
significant at 0.18 three but what
you're also seeing is that the p-value
isn't that big and the uplift is
negative so if you're going to your
product manager or whatever and you say
okay I raise the activity of our users
but we decrease the sales and we're
losing money then cry probably he would
say okay lets us test run a bit longer
with more users and see if we can get it
significant to see if we really losing
revenue if we're doing the test and all
of a sudden this positive uplift and the
activity won't matter that much and
that's where you can see that's a really
good common ground for discussing a/b
tests because in a single place you see
what have you done and how have you done
it and yeah you can really easily
discuss the implications that a be test
has okay then if you want to try it for
yourself then yeah you can easily do
that by just cloning a github repository
because we open sourced a B and we think
it's really easy way to document all
your a bee tests and it's
at least for us this was a huge huge
gain in productivity when it comes to
designing or documenting a/b tests so
thank you and if you have any questions
oh yeah does anyone have questions well
I guess I have one oh sorry thanks for
the talk I have well two questions which
one is a follow-up of them you said that
one does not simply do this kind of
tracking with excel but you started
doing it with excel at which point did
you decide that Excel was not enough
well we had it in Excel like you said
but it's really every test was a row in
the spreadsheet and the rows were
getting really long so that's the first
problem if you have a description for
your test and really a lot of test a
text isn't really feasible in a
spreadsheet that's the first problem
that you have and also if you don't come
up with the right format so you forgot
to evaluate to report some evaluation
metrics to maintain it backwardly it was
really a pain and then yeah it basically
was really that at some point we said
okay we need more control over a BTS
what were the results of it and we
needed to find a better solution so
basically that's it I mean if you have a
small start-up and you're doing three
a/b tests a year then it might be really
feasible to do it in a spreadsheet of
course yeah and the second question
would be did you have to convince any
manager to spend time did you have to
convince any part of the organization
that was not involved with a bit s that
they were not feeling your pain so you
could spend time building this tool
instead of doing every test the other
way well there was some groups so like I
said before we have quite a lot of
different people doing the a BTS ever
really developers designers and so on
marketing us
and basically when we started IBM we
introduced it to them than they were
like oh so I don't need my excel
spreadsheet anymore we like no but it's
great to know that you had one so we
went aware of it of course as a data
team you always want to be involved in
most kinds of a BTS and to know what's
going on with users in the results and
so it was really separate worlds and now
everybody has this in one singer place
and we leave benefits all of us thanks
hey thanks fighters I just want to say
and I see there's a lot of dependency
pandas and don't buy all these things
but how do you use them now but
basically panels and stats models and so
on are also only used for this test
evaluation part that you have so it's a
little library that we we're basically
wrap some methods from stats models and
put them in a uniform at it fits nicely
and yeah for the test documentation
itself you don't need it obviously it's
basically really just a django app okay
okay because I mean they're not imported
anywhere so they're not used in the app
they use somewhere else yeah it might be
yeah yeah this really can be artifacts
because we reflected in the sink single
absolute abbey itself yeah I would have
a look about thanks for noticing
I know what else actually I have a
question so first I was wondering if can
speak more about how you chose Django
over other frameworks and secondly when
I was running a be test we ran about 20
test a week and what I found difficult
was deciding on which to what new test
to try out so i thought i wants to get
your thoughts on perhaps using machine
learning to recommend new tests well the
reason for Jengo basically was i'm not a
developer so and but I built some
private projects using Django and I knew
it lends itself quite well for this crud
style applications we're just basically
putting something in a database or as a
possibility to update it to delete it
and it comes batteries included so it
was basically the easiest way land we
could also have done it using flowers
but it would have been more work to do
so and can you repeat the second
question I wanted to get your thoughts
on perhaps using machine learning to
recommend you test is try odd because
when I was doing in testing that was the
part I find the trickiest yeah I don't
know if machine learning is a good
companion in this case may be yesterday
was a talk about Trent research so maybe
you can come up with some trends that
you tested and did you test it
successfully so but I think most
importantly is using your product
yourself and you're developing on it and
you come up with an idea what to test
and feel okay it doesn't it isn't
perfect in the way it is now maybe from
the design or if a new features coming
up and that's the what to test is
basically I think mostly a matter of
intuition more than
machine learning task of itself any
other questions okay so let's have
another round of applause for Andy
you